and when they put him on my chest right
after he came out of me it was like oh
my god he is really a little baby and
he's really here and I wouldn't change
it for anything and now looking back I
mean I definitely regret and continuing
using drugs during my pregnancy Darian
dykes has struggled with heroin
addiction since she was 15 years old
over the years she had numerous failed
attempts at getting clean she found out
she was pregnant last year and despite
her best efforts struggled with her
addiction through most of her pregnancy
as a consequence her baby was born
dependent on the drug this is known as
neonatal abstinence syndrome or na s in
which the baby experiences drug
withdrawal symptoms
Tennessee has seen a tenfold increase in
na s over the last decade there are no
known long-term effects and the baby can
usually be weaned off the drug within a
few weeks after birth yes a lot of the
babies are showing great progress after
several weeks but that doesn't make the
behavior of the mothers okay recovery is
a complicated long process but for many
of these women there's no motivation to
get that help do addicted pregnant women
need the state to provide motivation to
seek help Shelby County District
Attorney Amy Weirich thinks so she's an
advocate for Tennessee chapter 8 2011
allows for a woman to be prosecuted for
assault for the illegal use of a
narcotic drug while pregnant if her
child is born harmed by those drugs
Tennessee is the first state to
criminalize substance abuse for pregnant
women the sentence could range from 1 to
15 years in prison it went into effect
this past July the way to address a
health crisis with the Department of
Health
Thomas Castelli of Tennessee's American
Civil Liberties Union says women's civil
rights are being violated I agree with
the people who say we need to address
this problem when a disagree with is
that the solution is to put people in
jail or into our criminal justice system
but ryuk says that's not the law's
intent the options that are available
for women that are charged under this
our drug court and the drug court
treatment that is provided through those
courts
if you successfully complete the
requirements of drug court your charges
are dismissed and they're expunged from
your record as if it never happened and
what we hope to do is get these women
some help for their addiction however up
to 70% of all drug court participants
will not complete the program according
to a 2005 government report and if they
fail the program then jail time is the
alternative opponents point out that
this creates a strange paradox on the
one hand if an addict successfully
complies with the drug court
she is overcoming an illness but if she
relapses then she's treated as a
criminal violates the Eighth Amendment
the Supreme Court determined that it
would be cruel and unusual to punish
people for having a status or having an
illness and in that case it was a
California law that criminalized being a
drug addict so we think this law
actually does the same thing it
criminalizes the illness of addiction
but if criminalizing their addiction
motivates them to find treatment isn't
about helping addicts in the long run
threatening them with a criminal justice
system doesn't help when you're living
in a in a state that doesn't have enough
addiction treatment centers as it is
generally much less for women who are
pregnant drug overdose is the leading
cause of death in Tennessee but there
are only 19 treatment facilities in the
entire state that offer care for
pregnant women and only two that provide
prenatal care and allow a woman's
existing children to accompany her to
treatment necessity for many of these
lower-income single mothers this
shortage has created long wait lists
that range from a few weeks to a few
months the biggest fear we have is that
it actually will deter women from
seeking medical prenatal medical
attention altogether for fear of being
prosecuted Darian beat the odds and was
lucky enough to receive care from dr.
Jessica Young the leading doctor at
Vanderbilt drug dependency clinic for
pregnant women luckily she gave birth
one month prior to the laws
implementation with a doctor's help
darienne's been clean now for nine
months and has a healthy baby boy when I
realized I was pregnant you know it took
me by shock for a day or two and then I
finally the maternal instinct kicked in
at that point in knowing that I was
going to be a mother
and you know a child depends on their
mother so I needed to do the right thing
for him basically I need to quit being
so selfish dr. Young says this is
natural she states pregnancy is often a
really motivating time for these women
to get their lives turned around so we
really have a critical time to work with
them this is a population of women who
are already scared they're already very
distrustful in general of authority and
medical establishment and it takes a
long time for them to build up trust so
this bill will make that harder
considering the high dropout rate of
compulsory rehab programs and unreliable
access to treatment facilities dr. young
might be right state mandated treatment
is unnecessary and even harmful women
there in the situation aren't monsters I
mean if they are gonna threaten these
women like this they need more treatment
programs as for Darian she plans on
maintaining her successful drug recovery
for the years to come I mean just the
joy he brings me from here in the little
giggle or seeing a little smile I mean
there's nothing else that can beat that
in life there's no drug that can give
you that feeling
you